mr speaker no one out in the country
wants these strikes to go ahead but as i
have repeatedly said even at this 11th
hour they can still be avoided to do so
it requires ministers to step up and
show leadership to get employers and the
unions round the table and address the
very serious issues on pay and on cuts
to safety and maintenance staff behind
this dispute
the entire country is about to be ground
to a halt but instead of intervening to
try and stop it the secretary of state
is washing his hands of any
responsibility
on the eve of the biggest rail dispute
in a generation taking place on his
watch he has still not lifted a finger
to resolve it
not one meeting mr speaker
no talks
no discussions
only media interviews and a petition to
the labour party
this is a grave dereliction of duty
and should these strikes go ahead
tomorrow they will represent a
catastrophic failure of leadership
ministers owe it to all those impacted
by this serious disruption to get around
the table for last-ditch talks to sort
it out and avert
this disruption
and if he won't listen to me mr speaker
sir can you two either go outside i'll
be quiet for a little while will we say
thank you mr speaker
if he won't listen to me mr speaker he
should at least listen to his own
colleague the honourable member for
rossendell and darwin his own former
parliamentary aide he said yesterday i
can tell you the only way out of a
dispute is via negotiation i'd call on
all parties including the government to
get around the table because this is
going to have a huge negative impact on
people's lives
his own mps and the public know the only
way to sort this out is for the member
opposite to do his job
but that isn't all mr speaker because
this week it was revealed that not only
has he been boycotting the talks he's
tied the hands of those at the table
he and his department failed to give the
train operating companies a party to
these talks
any mandate to negotiate
whatsoever one source close to the
negotiations said without a mandate from
government we can't even address the pay
question
today the rail delivery group confirmed
they hadn't even begun those discussions
that's the reality mr speaker these
talks are a sham
because ministers have set them up to
fail
it is for the government to settle this
dispute they are integral to these
negotiations they cannot be resolved
unless he
is at the table
but it is becoming clearer by the day
ministers would rather provoke this
dispute then lift a finger to resolve it
the same transport secretary that just a
few short weeks ago was feigning outrage
over the disgraceful behavior of piano
and who is now adopting their playbook
replacing skilled safety critical staff
with agency workers cannot and must not
be an option so what exactly has changed
between the secretary of state calling
on the public to boycott
piano and now that he is suggesting that
their behavior should be legalized
mr madame debts speaker tomorrow we will
see
unprecedented disruption
we have been clear
we do not want these strikes to happen
where we are in government we are doing
our job
in labor run wales a strike by train
staff has been avoided
employers unions and the government have
come together to manage change that's
what any responsible government would be
doing right now because whether it's
today tomorrow or next week the only way
this dispute will be resolved is with a
resolution on pay and job security the
secretary of state owes it to the
hundreds of thousands of workers who
depend on our railways and the tens of
thousands of workers employed on them to
find that deal because those rail
workers are not the enemy they are
people who showed real bravery during
the pandemic to keep our country going
who showed solidarity to make sure other
workers kept going into work
some lost colleagues and friends as a
result they are the very same people the
prime minister promised a high wage
economy to a year ago before presiding
over the biggest fall in living
standards since records began
there is still time for the secretary of
state to do the right thing the brave
thing and show responsibility
patients school children low-paid
workers the entire country
needs a resolution and they will not
forgive this government
if they do not step in and resolve it
even now at this late hour i urge him
get around the table and do your job